i think there's something about the more
difficult it is to get to a place it
seems like it's more valuable when
you're there
[Music]
as a photographer my end goal really is
to make people see the landscape in a
completely new perspective
it's about showing things in a different
light
[Music]
i don't really see myself as a
photographer
i see myself as an artist
working with
photography well i've always been pretty
obsessed with mountains rock formations
and pinnacles and that kind of thing
growing up in liverpool glaciers were
always something that i had never really
had that much access to when i was
approached by coarse light to shoot in
an incredible place like this i thought
it was a really great chance to show
something which wasn't seen before the
colour of the ice underneath the light
of the drone
tomorrow if we can go into pasta rory in
order to get to a really good viewpoint
we have to hike
new experiences are crucial for me
i'll just explore and see where it takes
me
[Music]
wow
the scale of this place is just
incredible
probably like it's going to get tougher
on this wall yeah i know it gets
anything i know it'll get steep
somewhere but you know i don't mind
going a little bit higher i think
there's more to discover
tonight i do want to come away with
compositions which are quite a bit
different
[Music]
when the full moon comes up everything
is going to be bathed in light so i
think it would be a good idea to start
shooting
like nowish
[Music]
one of the things about exploring a
landscape for me is being able to shoot
at night
i've been using drones with lights
attached to them and that allows me to
illuminate the landscape as you would in
a studio
that was kind of a challenge trying to
see in the dark
everything is more difficult at this
altitude
[Music]
the battery was kind of low and it kind
of landed badly
it's mainly this
i started losing fingers in my
index finger and
middle finger
i can't even speak properly because it's
so cold i'd like to test this again and
see if it works
[Music]
with this project i was seeking to
produce a series of images that tells
the story of this place and express my
own ideas of exploration
[Music]
i don't think i'll ever stop exploring
that's what it comes down to
going out of your comfort zone you know
each time you do something just push a
little bit further
[Music]
[Music]
you